hi friends are you considering a
lucrative career and working in a
brothel
well neither am i but if you are
considering such a new juncture in your
career
you will certainly enjoy today's guest
allison schrager an economist
and author of a book called an economist
walks into a brothel
and other unexpected places to
understand risk and of course the
subtitle is what was so fascinating to
me
we talked about many many different
things including the economics
and risk reduction mechanisms not only
for brothels
admittedly a little bit less applicable
to the erudite listeners of this very
podcast
but also risk reduction in things like
life insurance
even getting married having children we
talked about
all these topics as well as her
experiences with professional poker
players
big wave surfers nobel prize winning
economists and
other fascinating characters that make
up the many examples
and very clear and easy to understand
pros
uh in this book it's really an
unexpected little treat that i happen to
find out
from a well-known scientist robert
kiyosaki otherwise known as rich dead
slash poor dad i don't know but that's
uh where i heard about allison i
listened to his podcast and uh sometimes
it's pretty interesting you'll find
very very interesting intellectuals such
as allison schrager
so that was an unexpected place to find
her and i
am delighted that i did so stay tuned
today you'll find out
kind of the answers to many questions
that we take for granted
uh in a given day such as how early
should you leave to get to the airport
for your next flight
how you could handle the risks of
dealing with kovid versus you know
responding to a text message as you're
driving
your car and other very interesting
risk tidbits backed by good hard science
and really explained in a clear and
convincing way you'll hear about
allison's upcoming book
which also about risk and including risk
in love
and we just talked about so much stuff
today i know you're going to enjoy it so
sit back relax and enjoy
this episode of pandemic podcasting
into the impossible with yours truly
brian keating
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
uh welcome everybody to this episode of
into the impossible and today we have on
a change of pace a spectacular guest
who's written
a phenomenal book that i found out from
none other than
everyone's favorite economist and
financial advisor
robert kiyosaki yes rich dad poor dad
is where i first discovered alison
allison
is the author of the book an economist
walks into a brothel
and other amazing stories about how
human beings
can best manage that all elusive yet
all-important factor
of life which is risk and the management
thereof
and she offers a great deal of tactics
and tricks and strategies
for us to deal with risk in our lives
whether we be big wave surfers
whether we be uh stock market
aficionados
or whether we happen to work in a
brothel which i've stopped doing but
nevertheless is uh is one of the major
topics of the book so alison thank you
so much
for joining us today uh and i'm sorry it
took so long to get you on the podcast
but i've been fascinated with your book
and your work for a long time
thanks for joining us so much in the
into the impossible podcast
oh thanks so much for having me so uh
your book
has a provocative title and i wonder if
you'd be willing to do the following
which is to
explain to us first how you came up with
the title and the cover
for an economist walks into a brothel uh
and after that we'll play a game of risk
management where we look at
the various reviews that have been
garnered for this fantastic book
and we'll examine the dispersion the
the standard deviation of those
of those reviews if you're willing to do
so but first tell us
how did you come up with the name of the
book the title of the book and what it's
uh and what the subtitle is all about
well um i i'm terrible at titles i
did come up with the title but not as
the book title
uh when i sat down to write it you know
i i wrote down an economist walks into a
brothel because for me this was
an unusual journey i'm trained as an
economist later as a financial economist
so what we do
generally is we sit at our desks and
look at data actually going into the
world and talking to people
is generally not what economists do
we're not trained to
we're not encouraged we've got terrible
social skills it's not something we do
so um when i was making these trips to
the nevada brothels like it was just
weird for a lot of reasons one it was a
brothel it wasn't sort of the
environment i'd ever been to
but two it was just really testing my
research ability
i said i wasn't trained i'm not like an
anthropologist or a sociologist and i've
been trained to talk to people
so actually like studying an economic
subject up close
was for me just stepping into this other
world so
i said i'm not normally a good title
person when i was sitting down to write
that first chapter i kind of just wrote
it as a
chapter head just because it represented
to me
me crossing that line and then i didn't
think much of it i'd even forgotten it
was a chapter head i started
wrote the book and then the publisher
actually picks your title
and they picked a title i didn't love i
felt like it was kind of boring i don't
remember what it was that
tells you how boring it was and um
we kept fighting i'm like i feel like
there's a sexier title out there and i
kept throwing out ideas and they all
caught
explaining to me why they were so
terrible so
then they came back to me a couple weeks
later after we agreed on the bad title
and they were like we think you're right
we should go with something sexier we
realize it's in front of us the whole
time
we're going to go with the economist
walks into a brothel she said i even
forgot was a title
because they said it was so personal to
me and i was like
i instantly heard i'm like yes that's it
and the cover
i don't know if that's a lot less of a
sexy story again
you um are presented a lot of
first we had all these pictures like you
know art like i at my the books with
portfolio who has amazing
artists and they had all these like
pictures
of like women doing risque things and
we're still like uh i don't know this is
the right message this is really an
economics book a financial economics
book
so um we discussed that then they had a
meeting they had a lot of meetings with
the publisher and they said we had a
meeting
and we've decided you're right we're
just gonna go with words
and then there was a lot of boring
conversations i won't
torture you with about obsessing about
colors
well it is delightful if not sparse
cover
and as i mentioned what i've been doing
lately is exploring
the phase space of riskiness uh with
regard to authors who do come on the
podcast and i ask them
if they're willing to go truly into the
impossible and and
confront and respond to the highest
verified review on amazon and the lowest
verified review on amazon
it's kind of fun but if you are willing
we can do it if not
and they only use verified reviews
because they have
skin in the game as you talk about so i
will not accept a review by somebody
good or bad who hasn't bought the book
i'm sure i said i tend not to read
negative reviews but uh
yeah yeah i'm open to hearing it i guess
this is uh someone titled allison
schrager's mother
um the best book ever written no no this
is a someone named robert says the
cleverest application of economics
i know the title doesn't if the title
doesn't induce you to buy this book then
the first
few pages will do it allison schrager
has done a masterful job explaining in
plain english
using rather a ham examples and
illustrations
of how to take account and manage risk
in your life drawing on fundamental
lessons on
on finance and economics do you care to
rebut those accusations of this
five-star
verified review no no it's lovely uh
robert
i i actually don't even know robert but
that's a very kind uh
thing to say his last name is merton i
don't know if you um i'm just kidding
he did write you a review on the back of
the book uh we'll get to that in a bit
okay here's a negative review i almost
never write a book
that's net book review that's negative i
heard her on the show talking about some
aspect of politics as an example of
exercise and risk management
it was an unusual approach expressed
cogently and interesting
lee so i thought i bet her book is great
nope
once you get past the title the book's
ideas are not that well developed she
doesn't go deep enough into any of them
and but then he says i only made it
through half the book before giving up
so i disagree with this person you don't
have to disagree with them
but i found the book is like a tidal
wave of
unassailable knowledge and and wisdom
from disparate field so
i know what i would advise this person
but what would you advise them well
i mean you're not going to connect with
everyone um for me
the book i i found the ideas of
financial economics incredibly powerful
and poorly understood i think
so i was really inspired to write this
book so people could understand these
principles better because
i think they they they seem so subtle
but they're actually quite important
i think uh certainly as i've been
observing a lot of the conversation on
things like gamestop
and day trading how these principles of
risk really sound so simple
but they're really poorly understood um
so i mean my my idea for this book was
to
take these principles and make them
sound easy i remember the publisher when
i explained
the principles he's like you make hard
things sound easy
and sometimes people think because you
make something sound easy it is
and so maybe it just wasn't the right
format for this particular reader
yeah um i mean to some degree i feel
like if someone said and finish your
book that's on you i mean it's on me
the author because i mean it's it's my
background in journalism makes me feel
like i failed somehow if someone doesn't
keep reading
so um i don't blame him for not
finishing but maybe as i said it wasn't
the right format for him to learn or as
i said a lot of the
more negative feedback i got from people
was that it all sounded so obvious
but sometimes making something hard
sounds simple
i think is an interesting challenge and
i think a lot harder than making
something complicate easy sound
complicated
yeah yeah and certainly there's a a ton
of uh you know red meat as they say or
if you're vegan you know red tofu
for people that want to sink their teeth
into aspects that are quantitative
you give a thorough explanation of all
the greek symbols in the black shoals
equation
and and you do so in a in a
comprehensive manner but it's it's
entertaining
and with examples ranging from you know
how early or late
uh a route should you take to get to the
airport
for example which is one of the places i
want to start so i want to get your
opinion on a couple of
um canards or things that i've heard in
my career and then we'll get into risk
management
we'll touch upon gamestop and the stock
market and bitcoin
and then we'll talk about uh risk
management in other aspects of life
ranging from
family formation to other things we'll
stay away from the brothel we're not
going to go there
except to say that i believe it's true
that the mustang bunny ranch another
brothel
was forfeited to the federal government
after convictions for tax fraud by the
owners in the late 90s oh really
yeah and then oh that's right yeah and
then it was auctioned off and the
government
took a receivership and then it went out
of business
so in other words it was very successful
this is the apocryphal perhaps story but
anyway i just wanted to point that out
so here's a here's a saying that one of
my
very well-traveled well-heeled friends
tells me he said to me
if you're not missing one out of every
10
flights that you go to take you're
wasting too much time in the airport
how do you react to that uh to that
recommendation
well i definitely don't list that many
flights
i mean i think it depends on you know
how important that trip is to you um
i mean again i you know i do talk about
how much time do you need to get to the
airport because you know you don't
you shouldn't spend two hours waiting
for your flight but i think uh missing
one out of ten is also a little bit much
too
um it depends how comfortable you are
with missing or how good your
relationship is with the airline i think
that's the question is how well insured
are you
because if you don't have a good
relationship with the airline maybe you
just don't go on your trip and that's
kind of awful particularly if it's like
a vacation a family vacation
but i mean if you're uh you know uh have
diamond status at your airline they'll
probably get you on another plane
so i think what's the right amount of
flights to uh miss probably depends on
how well insured you are
which probably depends on how much
you've invested in your airline
relationship
so you know considering whether or not
there is a single strategy to reduce
risk
uh or not in some cases it seems like
there is a clear and maybe there's only
one strategy i mean there's a
there's an old joke not that funny that
goes something like this
you don't need a parachute to skydive
you just need a parachute if you want to
go skydiving a second time
and we actually have you know we don't
need to actually test that like
scientifically
visit in terms of physics of
gravitational force fields but
so there it's clear what the strategy
for risk mitigation is
but uh how does one go about choosing
between the different types of
strategies that you outline
uh ranging from insurance to uh
optionality to
to hedging to um you know kind of
diminution of profit etc
um what what kind of in on on a daily
basis you know we're not confronted with
whether you know going skydiving and not
using a parachute
but we we are confronted with situations
like car insurance or health insurance
i had on patrick bet david is a famous
uh
proprietor of a very popular youtube
channel but also deals with insurance
sales
and uh and i said to him you know it's
like insurance is unusual because
the insurance company you know you're
you're betting you're gonna die
and they're betting you're gonna live
and and you're you're taking all these
various but
so first let's go back and say what is
the origin of the word risk itself where
does it come from where does the concept
of quantitative risk come from
quantification um well there's a
contentious question but
as far as i know it's like based on
peter bernstein's book it means to dare
i mean and for a long time it meant i
guess the original origins
were it was a greek shipping term and it
meant something dangerous and still when
we talk about risk risky that usually
means something bad
but later i think around um the middle
ages or early renaissance
uh it changed this meeting which was
like this sort of middle english to dare
um or german i can't remember it's been
a while since i've been a book interview
and sorry so but it already
when around like so peter bernstein's
wonderful book is all about
how in i said late middle ages early
renaissance how
risk became something that could be
measured and controlled rather than just
left to fate
and that's when the meaning also changed
to include the upsides of risk and this
idea that you
had some control over the risks you took
really also changed its meaning to a lot
of people
although it is telling that usually when
we say risky we're referring to the bad
things that could happen and not the
good
so one of the examples you give in the
book aside from the
you know getting to the airport and
you're traveling your commute
uh involves essentially you know
portfolio
insurance and and other sorts of
concepts that people have
have used for many years and you point
out that the originator
of the theory behind how options should
be priced in the um uh black
scholes equation that they later went on
to
uh become advisors to uh to long-term
capital management which
it was you know proceed now it's funny
you know we can we can think about uh
epochs in terms of how many financial
crises ago was that
uh so now this is like two or three ago
uh in the early 2000s or late 90s when
they basically
it's funny now because the amount i
believe of their
uh notional shortfall that the
government bailed them out
was like 20 billion dollars not not a
small amount but
but i think you know today even you know
gamestop or whatever
uh is is many many times that market cap
we'll talk about that
but i want to ask you know how is it
that people that are so
astute at you know judging risk actually
pricing risk winning the nobel prize for
risk uh
quantification how do they still fall
victim
to uh sort of the most basic perils of
risk management
well i mean i think it's a complicated
story i mean first of all
long-term capital management was never
bailed out by the government they're
like
kind of similar to um the game stop
hedge funds
uh they were bailed out by other
hedgehog by other uh private players in
the financial markets which is i think
an important difference
when you don't have a tax ceremony at
stake um
and also i mean obviously i think one
reason why ltcm
required the government did organize the
bailout so i mean there's that
and the reason why that was necessary is
there was uh fixed income involved
and kind of like the financial crisis
you know you're more a lot more likely
to have a financial crisis when debts
involved rather than equity
like that's why you know there are a lot
of issues with gamestop which we can
discuss
but uh sort of systemic risk isn't
really something that
worries me so much i mean i guess it's
possible but it's a lot harder at
systemic risk when you're
playing around with equities compared to
debt um
that said you know even if you're super
smart i mean
you can underestimate risk we have these
very powerful tools to reduce risk
um you know i think behind ltcm there
there's a lot of you know
they you know according to um bill
owenstein book you know the
people in charge stopped listening to
the smart people in the room and started
taking on more and more risk because
they wanted to get more and more money
but i think at the core
there were more fundamental issues
certainly around leverage whenever you
take leverage you're going to magnify
your gains or your losses
and you know you can have this off
distribution
shock happen like in that case you know
with russia
and you know all of a sudden your models
don't work and i think that's
always a possibility and that's why no
matter how smart
you are or how many smart people you're
talking to you have to always
as i said be prepared for loss and for
things that you don't anticipate
i think i like to think now after a year
in which everyone sort of feels like
they had an off distribution risk
that you know we can all be more mindful
of that yeah
so yeah famously a great uh pro you know
proprietor of all things analytic
ranging from the uh conception
of the law of universal gravitation to
the
laws of behind calculus which is used of
course in all sorts of financial and
risk management
accounting practices he said this is
isaac newton
who participated in the south sea bubble
which is a trading company monopoly
trading company that went uh completely
uh belly up
back in the 1720s he said uh because he
fell victim to it he said i could
calculate the motions of the heavenly
stars
but not the madness of men
and i think it's pretty telling that you
know the more that we
think that we have uh a handle on the
future based on some modeling that we
have
uh reason to believe might be correct
but no data obviously because it's
forward-looking and future looking and
as the great philosopher of science yogi
bera said it's difficult to make
predictions
especially about the future and so we
have no idea whether or not
our models will be borne out in practice
but i wanted to talk now about a
personal issue
which involves the type of astronomy
that i do which is in collaboration with
colleagues literally in all seven
continents
and that's to build a new observatory in
this case
the simon's observatory named after jim
simons a hedge fund pioneer you might
have heard of him
and yeah yeah and and there of course
you know i have a video with jim simons
and
he explains the difference between alpha
and beta and other greek symbols that
you talk about too but
uh but in this uh campaign what we're
trying to do
is build the world's most ambitious
cosmic telescope
located at an altitude of 17 200 feet in
the north of chile the country of chile
in the southern hemisphere
so you know for five years now we've
been building this instrument
we've had to build a construction plant
we've had to build a concrete
mixing factory we have to bring our own
diesel fuel and generators
and all sorts of things have nothing to
do with astronomy but if you don't
account for them you will not be able to
construct the observatory it runs on
power and it sits on concrete
and around the world with vendors and
suppliers this is a 100 million dollar
project
and we have so-called risk registers
where we go over the likelihood of a
given event
the consequences if it comes true the
impact financially if it comes true
and mitigations if it comes so we had
very extensive risk registers across the
10 major subsections of this a new
ambitious observatory and we started
this years ago
and not one even though you know we're
some of the smartest people in the world
my colleagues at least
not calling myself in their august
company but
i get to play with them so it's fun
anyway not one of our risks
was coveted 19 pandemic will completely
eliminate the possibility of travel to
chile of vendor supply disruptions
of graduate students quitting families
being disrupted
why is it a valuable thing to look at
risk
with analytical continuous calculus and
models
when the most significant risks are
these black swans as as your uh
you know uh field co-member uh tele
calls these black swan events seem to be
much more
dramatic in impact than something you
can put a standard deviation attached to
so what's your feeling about that the
difference between catastrophic or
you know tail risks that really don't
lend themselves to probability
predictions
well i mean they work 90 of the time and
that's not nothing
right i mean uh you know it's good to
plan
i mean i think i i my last chapter is
about the risks you can't anticipate
and you know i spoke to h.r mcmaster
because the military
suffers with this too they want to plan
everything but nothing in battle goes
down as you expect it will
but that doesn't mean it's not worth
planning i mean first of all
you know it does work most of the time i
think the ques
the trick is you've got to be humble
about your plans you got to leave some
room you can't make your plans too rigid
you got to leave an ability to pivot
your plans because i mean there's also
something to the process that prepares
you four
things like a pandemic that like you
going through all these steps
and thinking through of all these
contingencies probably still left you
better prepared than
when the pandemic happened than if you
just you know kind of winged it
i mean because it does help you sort of
again have things on the ground
have more contacts uh all these sorts of
things you probably you said research
suppliers that you could get locally
you know all these things it's very
helpful that it helps you be better
prepared because the thing is that you
really need to prepare yourself
for the black swan event is to go in
well informed
and you know you're not going to know
everything in advance because the world
is so unpredictable
but the more informed you are for a
sort of uncertain event the better off
you're going to be
so uh famous uh stanford psychologist
carol dweck
uh put together some insights in a book
called mindset where she talks about
these different
objective you know kind of descriptions
of the human mind which
basically she she claims cleave into one
of two forms you know fixed
versus growth mindset where one is is
really looking
to quantify as much as possible to maybe
perhaps appear smart
and the belief is that say intelligence
or even forecasting ability
is fixed and the other one is kind of
learning based curiosity based
and wants to you know lend itself to a
tendency to learn
which by necessity as you point out all
good things require
some risk and even some bad things war
requires you know is a bad thing it's
awful that we have to have war on
occasion
uh but uh but you need to take risks in
order to succeed
um so when when you you know have this
assumption are there people that believe
that they're inherently
good at assessing risk uh and and do you
believe that someone can be you know
people say oh you're a mathematical
genius because i'm a physicist i say
that's not
the case but can someone be a risk
genius
i think good risk geniuses know what
they don't know i think to that
and speaking of that and they're
comfortable with the limits of their
knowledge
um you know i think that's what sets
apart good risk takers from bad risk
takers
um as i said it's like i i mean i i find
it very seductive myself like i like
modeling risk
i i have to admit this whole last year
which has posed so much uncertainty to
everyone
i i find risk modeling and staring at
data gives me a lot of comfort
because it helps me put numbers on
things um like over the summer i met up
with some friends i live in new york so
everything's shut down
yeah still but we're allowed to eat
outside anyway there's blizzards going
on yes exactly
amazing it was amazing i was walking
outside i
met a friend for dinner last night it
was 25 degrees and
we had to wait all the restaurants are
or the outdoor little structure they
have these little rickety structures
built in the streets right now everyone
eats and they're
full i mean we're a hearty people um
more than i would have expected but oh
yeah
so for the summer i was having dinner
with two friends but it was summer so it
was actually a pleasant thing to eat
outside
and my friends were like you know it's
crazy we're doing this
we're really just playing russian
roulette with our lives and i was like
you know i don't know about that i mean
you biked in city traffic to get here
i mean that's something in a million
years i would never ever do
um but like i'm comfortable eating
outdoors with friends during our
pandemic i mean it's it's
like i feel like looking at the data
that seems a lot less risky to me
yeah so i think i i'm generally like i
have survived this being a lot less
fearful because you know i spent a lot
of time looking at data
and that is my happy place but also
because i kind of
went into this kind of also accepting
that
you know [ __ ] happens and things you
can't predict and things you can't
control
and you can take steps to minimize and
mitigate your risk but
it's not going to ever go away and i
think that
that knowledge has really made me i
don't know served me well i don't know
if anyone's handled this great
but like has at least relieved me of
anxiety that other people have um
yeah it's funny that you mentioned the
covet kind of differential risk
management or willingness that people
are are taking on
uh oftentimes my wife will text me you
know as i'm driving the kids home from
school did you pick up the kids and i'm
like answering that question
or she'll ask you to text me like did
you put hand sanitizer on their hands
and i'll say you know me answering that
question is so much more dangerous as
i'm driving
than any risk of them contracting and
succumbing to some
side effect of covid the other thing i
see often on this campus at uc san diego
are you know students biking and tearing
around on their skateboards you know we
have the coolest students in the world
and they're on their skateboards and
they're on their phone and they've got
their mask on
and they don't wear a helmet and i'm
like this is nuts
like you know you're so much more you
know prone to getting you know i'm not
saying don't wear a mask
but like the fact that they ass you know
kind of a sign of risk probability of
covid is so much harsher
and and this goes off campus too it's
not but anyway those are just some fun
things that i've observed
the kind of disproportionate notion of
risk as you point out like a plane crash
you know claims a thousand
you know uh claims us you know 20 lives
that'll get make headlines but you know
every day a thousand people die in car
accidents right or you know
yeah like we've gotten very fixed it's
easy to get fixated on the risk that's
in front of you
and i think for a lot of people coveted
risk is what they obsess about
to the detriment of thinking about risks
we've actually lived with this whole
time and in fact
other risky behaviors that this might be
encouraging in us
um you know just because you're managing
coverage risk well doesn't mean you're
not managing other risks that well
yeah that's actually fascinating i was
listening to a podcast by another author
he's like a navy seal and
he was talking about how we have this
kind of i translated it into like a
co-processor
in our brain that our brain is getting
right now you know 13 million bits of
information
and we're just focusing right now we're
focusing on the podcast we're focusing
on our conversation
uh but you know you only can store in
your prefrontal concentration cortex
co-processor
about 3 000 bits of information every
second
which is a lot but actually much less
than than an image or something like
that
um so we think we're good at
multitasking we think we're good at risk
analysis but you're right
it's the thing that's right in front of
you that actually can overwhelm you know
the the key to this the guy said is like
you know if you get into a car accident
you're driving and listening to this pot
and i was i was like this guy watching
me like are the navy seals like
everywhere i want to be
uh but the navy seal guy was saying you
know basically you
uh you know you're listening to this
while you're driving because you've
offloaded
your conscious decisions about driving
to you know experience to past history
of driving
but if you get into a car accident i
guarantee you you're going to have to
rewind
the previous 30 seconds of this
conversation you're not going to be oh
multitasking crashing sharing
information
um but speaking of the military let's
let's go there because uh you point out
you know a good part of the book and one
of the
encomia on the book well deserve richly
deserved
is about the military and i was thinking
and from h.r mcmaster
who's uh who's a phenomenal uh
intellectual as you point out he's kind
of like this you know
business school professor mixed with you
know this warrior
kind of personality very interesting uh
human being
but you know it came to me as i'm
reading your book that the fact that
people
don't apprise risk but actually have an
outsized impression of how good they are
at uprising risk uh could be used for
some sort of you know
social arbitrage and of course i would
never do that but people do that
in in poker all the time they do that
you know that
that uh you know kind of people going on
tilt and you talk about phil hellmuth
and your studies of him
very fascinating example but um in
warfare it would seem like you know
all is fair in love and war we'll get to
love later
but in war do you believe do people take
advantage of the fact that the enemy
might not be as good at uprising risk
not only as they are but as they think
they are
yeah and i think uh the story that hr
told me
you know you know we usually think about
things when you know television's
not going our way i i spoke to him about
the battle of
20 of 77
have done a book interview and how you
know
in that first iraq war that first war
like it went so much easier than we
thought it would
i mean because the enemy just was weaker
than they expected sometimes it's
stronger sometimes it's weaker
but when we went back to iraq it turns
out they're a lot stronger than we
anticipated
and that that's his point is it's just
that you can you can
model things to death but once you have
people involved things are always going
to be
um uncertain because he said you don't
know how that person's risk modeling
operates you don't know what things are
important to them
as i said people can get fixated on one
risk the detriment of other risks
they might care to fight for something
stronger than you will and all these
things are always unpredictable
[Music]
how can risk be taken advantage of you
know aside from being venal
and and having all these negative
aspects that i have i started thinking
about academia
and academic risk and you go through in
your book you know that one of your
risks was to
you know uh was whether or not you go to
graduate school or to
you know and work with this eventual
nobel prize winner robert merton
gives another glowing endorsement but
what was that choice like
and i feel i find academias is very
interesting because
there's a huge amount of risk for
certain tracks in academia
and there's almost no risk in other
forms in other words if i
want to become a professor it's almost
as hard
being a professor of astrophysics and
cosmology
as i am as you know making it into the
nba or something like that or let's just
say it's
professional major league baseball which
uh a lot of economists like baseball so
i'm gonna assume you do too
uh but uh but but you know but it's very
easy it's extremely easy
to become what's called a postdoc which
i'm not saying you know they're not
good but there's so much more of a
market for
you know peop from on the on the
seller's side or for
for people to become post-doc so it
would be as if it was incredible
generally get professorships that's the
point i'm trying to make so it would be
like
as if it was very easy to get into
triple a baseball
imagine if it was like it was a piece of
cake you know even brian keaton can get
into triple a baseball anyway
but then it's impossible to get into
major league baseball but it's actually
very hard to get into triple a baseball
in other words as a gradient
you know it's harder to get into ml to
the major leagues than into
aaa but it's almost impossible to get
into triple a what i'm saying is in
academia
it's it's as hard to get a position in
academia as mlb
but it's the next stage below it is sort
of as easy as as you know getting a
getting on a high school team in a in a
you know town that only has eight kids
do most postdocs go on to academia or do
they do something else
uh no i don't think it's it's it's at
least in my field
many of them have gone on to academia
but at least a third
uh have gone on to non-academic
positions or you know non-academic but
still research in a national laboratory
nasa something like that
but cutting off the academic
professoriate track yeah and i imagine
with the quantitative and programming
skills there's a lot they can do yeah
yeah a lot of them go into finance
actually they go into clients
jim simons would only hire
mathematicians physicists astronomers
for a long time
uh he he has told uh many people and in
his biography etc that
you know he wanted only people that were
good at that and it turned out that even
some of my friends who were professors
of astronomy
left their tenured faculty position
which is the most coveted thing you can
get
perhaps in all of society to become
hedge fund traders
so anyway yeah it seems strange that
there is this kind of
risk inversion you know where you what
was the process like for you when you
had to make this decision
you know where you were going to go and
what direction your career would take
uh was it was it grading on you and i'll
ask you later advice to your former self
but what would you say sort of to to a
younger version of allison
contemplating that very risky decision
that you made
well in retrospect i made an insane risk
decision at the time
you know like much like uh you know
um your field uh economics it's not
really that big a risk going
i mean do i think doing a phd in like
french literature is a lot riskier
you know it's like seven years in the
job market that was my minor yeah
yeah but the job market is even worse i
mean because first of all like i i
believe anyone who has a phd
really has a lot of original critical
thinking skills that should translate
into a lot of jobs
but it's hard to convince people in the
job market who haven't been through the
process
that's true um if you have a
quantitative phd
you know people are more inclined to see
you as skilled um
but you know there's even fewer jobs for
french literature professors
that's right so i think if you're doing
a quantitative phd
it's really never that risky i mean you
probably could do something that's
shorter and easier and you'd make the
same amount of money in the end
um and probably have a more certain
career path
but i mean if you if you really have
this intellectual need
to do this degree then you know i don't
think it's
a risky endeavor and that was definitely
true for me probably for you too
economics was something i really had
this need to take all the way
you know i i always knew this was
something i was going to pursue to that
level
i think from the first economics class i
took as a high school student like i
just
knew i had to go all the way with us so
i had that intellectual drive
the problem was i kind of went into it
without really a plan like
unlike um your field in economics
you know if you want to work as a
professor and tenure track job you're
probably going to find something
somewhere
economists are super rational and
there's a lot of jobs outside of
academia so
most people are like quite happy to go
to government to go into industry
so it's a pretty fluid market where
people want to go into academia do and
those who don't do and you know no shame
on that
um oh there's shame on that but like if
you do it you don't you don't care
um but i kind of really got wrapped up
with my research in grad school but
never really thought about being a
professor
until i became went on the job market
and i was just like
every interview i'm like i desperately
do not want to be here and i cannot
imagine doing this with my life i mean
it's wonderful
i said i'm super lucky as i said a
french literature phd would have killed
for that sort of opportunity
but i just realized it wasn't for me um
and so i i did something really insane
which was i i i managed to will myself
to graduate without a job which was
very unusual and considered a great
shame in my department and
brought great shame upon my committee as
i was told many times
um and i ended up like writing
an economics blog for the economist this
was like 2006 so i mean this was
really like kind of low level and kind
of embarrassing
but i just kind of wanted to start
something fresh i don't know a phd is
super hard you
you know there's it was just a whole i
mean i enjoyed it intellectually but
personally it's a very difficult process
so i just wanted to do something
completely different um
so that's i guess was the start of my
writing career which ended up as i said
anyway going into journalism with a
quantitative phd is a questionable
choice it did teach me how to write
which is a very valuable skill
especially
paired with a quantitative skill set so
in the end it did work out and they said
i was only the economist for a couple
months before i met martin and he took
me under his wing and taught me finance
so that turned out to be a good thing
too i think that's the thing you learned
in this whole process
is if you have a good education
particularly if you have a quantitative
phd
you're never really going to be in
trouble right um
you know i i think i wouldn't recommend
a lot of people take the sort of risks i
did
but having the sort of level of degree i
had was a great insurance policy because
you know you're always kind of kind of
be employable
and have the skills to give get you get
to get you what you need
yeah my advice for you know people that
want to go into academia is different
from that
those that want to pursue a phd and
that's you know you should go into
academia
if and only if and that's sort of the
advice i'd give to someone writing a
book
if you there's no other option in other
words if there's
if you don't do it you will be forever
miserable and if there's no one else
who can do what you're going to do in
your book or in your research or
even you have the passion that you have
if not the
you know mathematical ability or
whatsoever so only do it but the
fallback is
yes as you say not only will we pay you
in graduate school
to get your phd not not great you know
it's it's minimum wage-ish
uh currently uh we can talk about
minimum wage impacts some other time
but uh because i imagine you have very
many strong opinions and facts about it
but nevertheless yes you say there's
base i have zero thank
god or whoever zero unemployment amongst
the
17 plus students that i've had graduate
with phds in my laboratory so i'm very
proud of that it's probably my proudest
accomplishment is that
i always say to them my job is to get
you your next job what you do after that
that's on you in other words i'll get
you to the next point i'll get you
prepared whatever you tell me but you
have to tell me every year we have a
meeting i say are you still
on track to do goal x from last year
goal y
and z and if it changes that's totally
cool the facts change i changed my mind
as a famous economist once said right
um i want to talk about uh that's not
you sound like a good advisor
i think that that's my students you know
i mean what makes a phd so terrible is
also what makes it so valuable
is that you're in your 20s and someone
says come up with an original idea
and most original ideas are either wrong
derivative
or trivial and i think having someone
point out that your ideas are wrong
trivial or
um or derivative actually hurts a lot
but is actually useful in life
yeah yeah i think the notion that you
know everybody's above average
you know that goes to ucsd or some other
place
yeah it's it's it it's you know
ultimately not as helpful
as you could i want to get back to this
topic let me just take a quick break to
mention my guest today is none other
than an incomparable writer whose work
i love tremendously and i think this is
your first and
only book so far right allison yep
alison schrager is our guest today
author of an economist walks into a
brothel and other
unexpected places to understand risk
which
i do come away with a fantastic
understanding of in a way that i didn't
really appreciate
from disparate examples ranging from
poker to getting to the airport
uh to uh just to skydive or to
big wave surfing many other things just
tickles me and is a delightful book
uh has a 4.6 star rating 216 ratings on
amazon
and i want to get into amazon i want to
get into kind of the marketplace of of
books and so forth
what what did you learn about like the
publishing industry the economics
thereof
and their risk management you already
mentioned a few things which i agree
with completely
that they won't let you touch the cover
you think as an author oh i'm going to
make this
you know amazing cover and they're like
no we're not because they know
that people judge books by their covers
which is what i you know joke about at
the beginning of the podcast but what
did you learn if anything about the
unexpected risk management techniques of
modern day publishing
well so i have a chapter about the movie
industry and how
you know most movies lose money but you
have these unicorns it's like vc
investing that pay off for everyone
to some degree that's the publishing
industry i think that
describes fiction more than non-fiction
non-fiction
has a leskew distribution but still
somewhat skewed
and like i you know i'm working on my
second book proposal now
and it's amazing to me that every i'm
sure you heard this too is every every
time somebody's you're writing a book
somebody's like oh i've always dreamed
of writing a book
yeah and it seems so weird to me because
i mean i love writing books i'm
so lucky that i get to do that but it is
really i think the way you have to
approach it with a publisher certainly
in the non-fiction world i don't
understand how fiction works at all so i
can't comment on it
is it like i feel like i'm i'm like i
have a business idea and i have to
convince
a publisher to effectively invest in it
you know it's
here's this idea i have here's how i'm
going to execute it
here's my marketing plan here's how i
can sell it
here's who it's going to here's a
product that people are actually going
to buy
and with non-fiction is it you just
going to write your proposal
and you sell it that way and it really
feels less like
a creative literary exercise and more
like someone convincing someone to
invest in your business idea
yeah so another risky thing that people
take on
uh quite frank quite frequently is
as they enter into a very potentially
high level of risk uh contract in some
sense
social contract financial contract and
that's called marriage
and in fact you know the only issue i
take with
the book is is that you say that
marrying young is a risk
which you know it can be a risk but the
question is
uh are the risks offset by the rewards i
mean everything that derives from
marriage
including you know potentially children
um
you know is is is fraught with risk
right you never know like
children are like the box of chocolates
and forest gump you know you never know
what you're gonna get
uh so it's true and you never know
people change and if you marry younger
the probability for someone to change is
i always say people do change you know
people the phrases people don't change
but you know
people do change for the worse uh but uh
what do you say to someone like me
you know who says that uh there's great
benefits also to
getting married young and having
children young because you have a
greater
amount of memory dividend to kind of
draw from i had bill perkins author of
die
with zero on the podcast at the end of
last year
and his whole point is that memories
compound
in that the same way financial interest
compounds the greatest
invention of the human mind according to
this guy albert einstein
is the notion that interest compounds
kind of while you sleep
and his point is memories compound two
so
just like the hockey stick curve of
exponential growth
really turns up the heat towards the end
that behooves you to start early so
um what what is the basis of the claim
that it's risky maybe
maybe you don't think it's it's too
risky but is it why is it such a big
risk
to get married when you're young well
there's good risk and there's bad risk
and any risk you take has upside and
downside right
if you end up marrying the right person
young you have this life partner and you
get to grow with them and you have
children with them and that's
amazing right like i imagine there's i i
i'm not married so i imagine there's few
things you know more sad
like wonderful than that as i said like
having truly
a life partner who you grow with of
course the the downside
risk is you grow in different directions
and you're unhappy um
so as i said it's a risk but there are
upsides and downsides i think
it's it's all good if you marry the
right person and i think there is an
effective
risk management tool in marriage which
is
used by about 50 of all the people who
get married
and that's called divorce you know it's
one thing if there was no possibility to
get out you know we
we joke in academia that you know
marriage is less risky
than granting someone tenure because you
know if we grant someone tenure we're
with her
him for the rest of our lives and
actually some of us see our
work colleagues more often than we see
our home uh family
so yeah the only thing i would say is is
that yeah that if you
as you say with investment you know it's
it's it's not always clear that getting
started young
is the best track because you could
expose yourself to great losses but
usually people have less at stake
and and when you get married young you
don't have this huge portfolio that
would get divided in half at least in
the state of california
yeah so i'm working on my new book now
which is all about exploring why we're
hesitant to take risks and i've been
delving into i've been talking a lot to
the anthropologist helen fisher
about risk and relationships and people
taking risks and relationships
and she's noticed that i mean i think my
general book thesis is that people
are becoming more and more risk-averse
and she's like she sees that a lot in
relationships she's like she's the
chief scientist at match.com and is that
an anthropologist who studies love
that people are getting later prenups
are a lot more common
that people really need to feel like
they've known someone much longer
that and generally we are taking fewer
risks in marriage and
getting married very young is becoming
less and less common
yes uh that does seem to be the case and
uh and especially with children you know
i've learned you know having children
uh is as i said fraught with risk
obviously there's physical financial et
cetera
but you know there's also one one of my
colleagues a russian
fellow who said something in a
traditional russian way which is you
know that
you need there's only one condition for
me to have a kid and that's
you have to take the kids skiing and i
was like what the heck does that mean
and he was like because to go skiing you
need to have enough financial
mobility mobility you need to have
enough free time
leisure you need to be healthy enough
you need to have a child you need to
potentially get married to have a child
and although
obviously many people don't and that's
fine uh but yes they're they're you know
kind of
criteria and why people have children
but never do so many people
get into something that's so risky as
marriage or you know and and that
commitment
with as you know less attention paid to
it than
even their ira or you know our vacation
that they're going to take
we have a bunch of friends that are
happily getting married uh in the near
future
and you know it's like their plans
change at a on a whim and
uh and something even clearer that you
know we need these huge weddings and now
that kovit is is showing
you know kind of the links that people
go to to get married or avoid marriage
uh i think it's it's permanently changed
and that was kind of leading me to your
next my next question for you is
if you wrote the book again you know
knowing what's happened with covid
would you change anything or would you
amplify certain messages or would you
point specific people such as the
the person who shall not be named who
gave you this low star review
uh that didn't finish the book what are
some of the
you know ways that you might reevaluate
or amplify
the claims that and the and the
arguments you make in the book
um well i don't think i really would
change that much i mean if i wrote it
now i would be able to travel meet all
those people i guess that would be
different
um but i think i think for me it really
sort of
hammered home the message i for the
greek version i actually did write a new
intro for it
in honor of kovid um i can't remember
what i wrote
but uh because it was like in june but
um
and you know time has lost all meaning
um but
i i you know i think it's like these
lessons are more powerful than ever
i mean we live in a world where we crave
so much certainty but the world's never
going to give us that
but we have tools to make us feel more
comfortable to make sense of things to
accept that the world
is is it like risk modeling to me as i
said is trying
to make sense of uncertainty it's trying
to put parameters around it it's using
the math that we're all so comfortable
with
to make us feel more comfortable but
ultimately as i said all these things
happen you never anticipate
but i think if you're well trained as a
risk scientist
you anticipate that you know how to
adapt your models
as things come up and you understand
most importantly
how limited your models are and this
really just
works to make things this is a framework
to make sense of things
yes it does seem like you know having a
plan as they say in chess is better than
no plan even a bad plan
beats no plan uh and then of course um
the philosopher of science mike tyson
said you know everybody has a plan until
they get punched in the face which seems
you know provocatively
risky in my opinion um what do you make
about
uh since you are an economist um i want
to ask you about things like bitcoin
and and so forth in robin hood are these
effective ways in your opinion to
mitigate risk well actually first
bitcoin what
what are your take what's your take on
that i had michael saylor on recently
and he's
really extolling the virtues of it as
kind of thermodynamically
and scientifically sound money but as a
risk against inflation it seems like
it's lost its purpose as a
currency because you basically can't get
a bitcoin you can't make change of a
bitcoin
or some satoshis but uh so it's lost
that motivation and even he doesn't
extol that particular virtue but instead
as a
his uh hedge against inflation so what
what's your opinion as a professional
economist well um i think for both that
and say day trading on robin hood i mean
you're just taking adding risk to your
portfolio i mean that's what you're
doing with both of these
i mean i don't see bitcoin in any way as
a risk hedge
i mean i guess like part of the argument
is if the us government collapses then
you know you'll have your bitcoin
if dollars don't exist but i feel like
in that scenario why would you have
access to computers either
that you know you know it seems like the
whole world falls apart i'm not quite
sure why bitcoin would still be standing
i guess that's a catastrophic black swan
risk but just an ordinary risk he says
the inflation the real rate of inflation
for those of us who want to buy houses
you know in a desirable city or want to
buy you know a car or
something collectible or even you know
some things besides
oil have been going up at about 10 to 15
percent
in real inflation you know adjusted
terms i mean are not adjusted terms in
in real terms
and so his point is that you know that's
a known known
and rumsfeld yeah but there's a lot of
currency risk on bitcoin though i mean
it's not a good hedge for anything as i
said it just
it's like it's like people who had who
buy gold to hedge the dollar
it's like it's a lot more volatile than
even owning the s p 500
so i mean you're taking on something
insanely risky
to hedge a fairly small risk um
my i've never i don't know any bitcoin
my closest experience with it when i was
doing a story on the dark web
it was i spoke to a lot of internet drug
dealers on reddit about their experience
with bitcoin and they hated using it
because you know they when they make a
transaction on the dark web
the money sits in escrow until the drugs
arrive and the person uses it and
they're like all right this is what i
paid for
so in two weeks of your money sitting in
escrow the currency risk would
completely wipe out their profits
so it's really like it seems to me that
bitcoin has an incredibly high beta
so it's just like a way of amplifying
market risk
so um you know people wanna i mean with
with risk there is reward and i think
the same is true of day trading
um you know the whole discussion around
um
gamestop has made me realize just how
much people have lost sight of what
investing
means which is you know you buy an
individual security
really because of what it does to your
risk portfolio ideally
you want something that's not correlated
with your other assets so it reduces
risk
at the same time you can earn more than
holding cash maybe you decide you want
to take more risks so you add more risk
to your portfolio
but everyone's talking about investing
as if it's all about just picking these
individual stocks that are winners
which isn't hard and impossible you can
never do that consistently unless you're
jim simons
and you know there's not many of him
there's like him and warren buffett and
that's pretty much it
so odds are you're not one of them
and you are going up against them and
they've got a lot more money than you do
and you know having deep pockets or
access to a lot of capital certainly
helps in your investing
so it's bizarre to me that everyone's
now fighting for the little guy to day
trade like this
should not be the goal you know there's
a lot of good ways to invest
and i you know people want to sort of
play around with bitcoin and you know
day trade stocks it's not something i
would do but like i i wish them well but
i think they should understand that they
should only do that with money they're
prepared to lose
yeah well i mean here's a sailors you
know a steel man
of the bitcoin position which is that
you know over
any five-year period of time bitcoin has
gone up and
since its invention in 2010 has gone up
uh by effectively over a hundred percent
a year
even but that's a very there's a very
very short history i mean this is
something that makes me crazy
so when i was at dfa and like really
obsessing about how to model
equity returns and bond returns i was
working a lot with fama
and you know the thing is about they've
learned the hard way
because they've been around for a lot
longer is the way you predict
and model asset prices is to use as much
data as possible
in 10 years tells you nothing that's not
even a cycle
no right but people say things uh you
know about well there were seashells
that that
isaac newton invested in there was you
know
baseball cards you know there are all
sorts of things that don't have
uh that don't have an actual return in
terms of
you know a long history of value for and
even things that do have a history like
large stones in easter island uh you
know carried a lot of value for
thousands of years and and
you know gold is of course you know the
quintessential store value he points out
that two or three percent
you know because he's heard all the
arguments that you're making and he
points out you know every year people
mine you know two percent of the stock
of gold is added each year and even
warren buffett agrees with him warren
buffett doesn't think
gold is a fantastic investment vehicle
uh you know and even in terms of store
of value it fluctuates too it's not a
good
currency i mean try going down to the to
the
bodega on your corner in manhattan and
scraping off some gold flake and getting
a coffee
i guarantee they won't accept it you
know whereas bitcoin
it has this kind of portability it has
uh you know this this cryptographic
mathematical foundation
it weighs nothing you can take delivery
of it instantaneously unlike gold
unlike seashells and unlike you know
famous works of art and so what's
fascinating to me is that
actually on the dark web people are not
using it for the reason that you
mentioned but also because
the ledger is publicly available and so
people feel like they don't conduct the
same kind of illicit transit it's gone
down
from ten percent to one percent and then
sailor will say to me and to you
he'll say well how much illegal activity
is the us dollar used for
you know it's just like yeah well no i
only bring it up not because people use
it illegally but just because it's a
very hard currency to work with when
something has so much value
i mean you could argue the us dollar is
not
really truly fiat because it is backed
by goods and services of the us economy
so i mean yeah sometimes tulip bulbs or
sea shells get worth a lot but
you never know when they're going to
stop being worth something right
so because they do have no intrinsic
value and that's the thing 10 years of
data tells you
almost nothing it doesn't tell you
whether or not there's still going to be
bitcoin in 10 or 15 years maybe maybe
not
100 years 200 years who knows so
i mean and that's the thing about
investing it's not about picking the
right stock that goes
up for a week it's about being able to
consistently make money in markets over
time
and it's a very very few people are able
to do that yeah
because you have to know when to get out
and that's just very very hard
yep absolutely okay great allison this
has been so much fun i wonder if we are
now
going to be willing to go into the
impossible where i ask you
questions i ask all of my guests on the
into the impossible podcast
these are things kind of big picture
futuristic things and past advice that
you might give to your former self
so if it's okay with you we'll switch
into that mode uh and wrap up the
podcast okay
question the first question is an easy
question and that is
whether or not in uh in a uh hyperbolic
calculus fashion if you can
unite the form of gravity with the force
field
of quantum mechanics is that can we do
that no just kidding
all right the first question is uh is
what you would put in your ethical will
so you're
a mentor and friend uh tom uh merton is
it thomas martin or robert
i just love it robert he uh he won this
medallion here that was endowed by
alfred nobel who knew a thing or two
about risk he invented dynamite
and he wanted it used for good things
and bad things uh but knowing that it
was used for bad things he hedged his
legacy by endowing the nobel prize as
sort of a
a way to rehabilitate the way the world
perceived him after being falsely
attributed his death his brother's death
was falsely attributed to his
and so he endowed a will that not only
was meant to reward financially and with
a golden chunk of metal
uh but uh the scientists who had made
great discoveries
in physics chemistry etc later economics
was added controversially and the nobel
family
does not like that but anyway that's a
subject and i discuss in my book but uh
not for now
uh nevertheless the other uh requirement
is that the winners of the nobel prize
must better
mankind or humankind as we say nowadays
uh so i wanna ask you and that's made it
part of his ethical will
uh what wisdom and so forth he wanted to
bestow i ask you
uh when you reach the biblical age of
120 years old
what kind of uh advice what kind of
wisdom what kind of values
do you most want to communicate to your
ideological heirs oh
that's a heavy question
um i think it would be about seeking
knowledge as you said
in always being aware of what you don't
know and being curious
and interested in other people oh very
good uh the next question that i asked
my listener or my guest rather
uh is uh relates to a scene in the movie
2001 a space odyssey i don't know if
you've ever seen that movie
well well there's a notion that there's
a civilization
that leaves this kind of opaque piece of
technology called a monolith
uh for humanity to discover uh when it's
capable of decoding the message they're
in so sort of a time capsule meant to
last for billions of years
i actually had on carl sagan's widow ann
drurian
who is a brilliant writer producer not a
scientist and
i asked her the same question i'm about
to ask you what would you put on a
billion year long lasting time capsule
and she said oh i did that and i said
well that's pretty cool she said yeah i
recorded my brain waves and sent them
into
interstellar space and the voyager 1
spacecraft thanks to carl sagan
so i'm not expecting that you have that
same uh you know kind of uh
you know access to technology like that
but i do want to ask you
in economics in other aspects of life
what kind of
sentence or item or you know belief
system would you put
on a time capsule for people human
beings to discover millions or maybe
even billions of years from now should
we last that long
[Music]
huh well i guess that would be two books
um it would be
peter bernstein's book and maybe the
wealth of nations wow
because i think you know markets really
are an amazing
thing and we really can't get around how
useful they are
and we always want to try to do better
we always think we can out smart markets
but we never can
very good okay the last question instead
of going forwards in time
you know 100 years or a billion years
now we're going to go backwards in time
and uh and explore one of arthur c
clarke's famous
laws the first law is that any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and
actually open every podcast with those
very words said in sir arthur c clarke's
actual voice
the second law you might appreciate is
for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert and
the third law
is the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
and that's the name of this podcast
origin i want to ask you
uh for advice to your former self what
aspect of life
seemed impossible to a 20 year old
version of allison
uh that it now became possible because
of the courage you had to go
into the impossibles advice to your
former self
i would have never in a million years
thought i could get paid to do hard math
problems or write
two things i was never particularly good
at
wow so life i think so i guess i would
just say if you work really hard
like i i think i overestimated when i
was 20 how much natural ability mattered
i would have thought you need to be
extremely talented at both these things
and i'm not but no one will work harder
and that turned out to be important
wow very very nice okay allison this has
been a fascinating
uh conversation for me i know my
listenership around the world will
appreciate this i'll just sum up allison
schrager as an economist a senior fellow
the manhattan institute contributing
editor at city journal
and a co-founder of lifecycle finance
partners a risk advisory firm and maybe
i should have
you know kind of uh gotten a picture
brains and gotten some free financial
and risk analysis advice or maybe
do you work with scientist allison maybe
i could be your first scientific client
hey whatever you're interested in or we
could talk about it
awesome allison i want to thank you so
much i want to wish you to stay warm i
know there's a huge snowstorm out there
on the east coast and uh stay
safe of course you have to stay
risk-free no no we can't be risk-free
you taught me that have a wonderful day
allison thank you so much thank you
thank you so much for having me
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you